[music]
this time we in the council dealt with two
very important legal acts, which
above all concern the reform package for the
future of the common agricultural policy,
we have the progress report on the
processing of the horizontal regulation
on the financing of the administration and
the control system of the common
agricultural policy as well as just  the
regulation on the common
organization of the market in
agricultural products and the
austrian presidency of the council also presented it,
we negotiated intensively and
i think we came to a really
balanced agreement on the
fishing quotas for deep-sea
species, we managed to come up with a sensible compromise in terms of
the common fisheries policy
between
ecological, social and
economic goals to be
achieved today's agreement essentially follows the
catch levels proposed by the european commission
for a series of deep they
passed we al  so discussed
implement on the nff the european
management fish rees found on the
before after views of its existence
only tell team present on the found has
been implemented november countries
negotiated million user scoping study
and on the